let's try I hope this is correct geray
from Atlanta is that how I pronounce it
pronounce Gyra uh you're okay from
Atlanta welcome gyro I apologize
uh so I was in an argument
and I was telling you how the burn proof
is on the people claiming that the
election is false and he made like a
point about how like people on the right
just don't trust the elections and I
told them the reason they don't trusted
him is because political figures like
Trump tell them that they can't trust it
correct and he brought up a point how uh
like Trump was since supported the
vaccine was telling his supporters to
get it uh but they didn't really like
blindly follow him on that issue and I
didn't know how to cure it so I was
trying to ask like how you would counter
that
you it doesn't it doesn't need to be
countered I mean it's just they're two
different things so on the vaccines the
issue was
Trump initially convinced some people on
vaccines by saying he developed them
okay but then the rollout of the
vaccines was mostly under Joe Biden so
then a lot of them were able to kind of
off-ramp by saying well
it's not it's less about the vaccines
per se which Trump did do a good job in
developing but it's about how they're
being forced upon me by Joe Biden so for
a lot of it was just a different
situation when it comes to the election
stuff they got the idea that it was
stolen from the things Trump said and
Mike pillow and Sidney Powell and Rudy
Giuliani I mean where else would they
get it where else would they get it and
then on the vaccine thing if you present
them with what what we're talking about
here a lot of them would say well I was
able to do my own research on the
vaccines like the research is a joke and
it's nonsense but when it comes to the
election stuff it's not about research
they did it's just quite literally the
stuff that Trump and others have been
saying so I don't even really get the
Ana it's one of these kind of weird
analogies that doesn't really make any
sense
got you thank you
all right thank you very much for the
call appreciate hearing from our friends
in Georgia remember to vote remember to
vote in Georgia